my name is Juliana naughty I have two
children a boy and a girl
they're adopted actually we lived
together with my grandma in my aunt's in
a craft a capital of Ghana I think it's
interesting to live here just a bit
crowded very busy in terms of traffic
lots of houses can say this is where
most of the action is I worked as a
seamstress I did a three-year force in
tailoring and I'm I started this is my
first shop I've been here since 2010 I
leave home by 8:30 I get here first
I open up I prepare the police cut a few
things for the day and yeah I get
started I used to employ three people
but now I employ two because of a few
challenges that I I had was a year we've
been experiencing power outages we we
used to go of 24 hours 24 hours no
electricity and you have 12 hours and it
could be day or night so if it's in the
night means the whole day there's no
production I was not able to meet a lot
of customer demands keep postponing and
it's not good for business
I'm quite optimistic about the future of
Ghana and out one day like to see Ghana
like South Africa yes I think there are
still good people here how big things
with maybe you can all do it together
wake from Monday to Friday
but I don't have any engagements I still
come to a competitive if I'm really
really really pressed I work on Sundays
everything I've had a holiday Karuna had
a holiday in ages I normally so for
individual the individuals bring their
own fabric I only have to get buttons
and I get zips and this can take a whole
day to make this outfit other skates are
not money long it's quite a huge person
in the next 12 months one thing that my
heart really desires is to have my own
label and it's just so children's
clothing and be selling them final
product
imagine it you realize at the end of the
day have I've done a very good job is a
person satisfied that's that's when you
are yeah you know that you come out with
something nice something good that's
that's what I've always wanted to do
you